- [Instructor] We are
told, suppose we multiply
a complex number Z by -1-i.
So this is Z right over here.
Which point represents
the product of Z and -1-I?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So the way I think about this is,
when you multiply by a complex number,
you are going to rotate by the argument
of that complex number.
And you're going to scale the modulus of Z
by the modulus of this complex number.
Now, let me just think
about that a little bit.
So I'm gonna draw another
complex plane here.
And so this is my real axis,
this is my imaginary
axis, right over here.
And -1-I, so that's -1 and then minus 1i.
So it would go right over there.
It would be that right over here.
And so let's think about two things.
Let's think about what its argument is,
and let's think about
what it's modulus is.
So its argument is going to
be this angle right over here.
And you might already recognize
that if this has a length of one,
if this has a length of one,
or another way of thinking about,
this has a length of one,
this is a 45, 45, 90 triangle.
So this is 45 degrees
but then of course you
have this 180 before that.
So that's going to be 180 plus
45, is a 225 degree argument.
So the argument here is going
to be equal to 225 degrees.
So when you multiply by this,
you are going to rotate by 225 degrees.
So let's see this is going
to be rotating by 180 degrees
and then another 45.
So if you just rotate it by that,
you would end up right over here.
Now we also are going
to scale the modulus.
And you can see two choices
that scale that modulus.
And so we know it's going
to be choice A or choice B
because choices C or D
you'd have to rotate more
to get over there.
And so to think about that,
we have to just think about the modulus
of -1-i, this point right over here
and then just scale up this
modulus by that same amount.
Well, the modulus is just the distance
from zero in the complex plane.
So it's going to be this
distance right over here.
And you could use the Pythagorean theorem
to know that this squared,
if you call this C,
C squared is equal to one
squared plus one squared
or C squared is equal to two
or C is equal to the square root of two.
So that's the modulus right over here.
Modulus is equal to square root of two
which is approximately, it's
a little bit more than 1.4.
So let's just call it approximately 1.4.
So not only going to
rotate by 225 degrees,
we're going to scale the modulus,
the distance from the origin by 1.4.
So it looks like it's three units
from the origin right over here.
If you multiply that by 1.4,
three times 1.4 is about
four, or it is exactly 4.2.
So 4.2 of these units is
one, two, three, four,
a little bit further,
you get right over here
to choice B and we're done.